13.8 billion years ago the universe as
we know it began with a big bang and
everything that we know and are and are
made of was created 50,000 years ago our
brains underwent a major genetic
mutation which resulted in the
biological reorganization of the brain
some scientists call this the big brain
bang others call it the great leap
forward which I prefer it's so much more
poetic this is when Homo sapiens began
to evolve into the modern species that
we are today
the great leap forward activated most of
our modern abilities abstract thought
planning cooking competitive labour
language art music and self decoration
after the great leap forward there was
an explosion of stone tool making more
sophisticated weaponry and 32,000 years
ago the creation of our first
sophisticated mark-making on the cave
walls of less cow it's not a coincidence
that we've gone from documenting our
reality on the cave walls of less cow to
the walls of Facebook and in a very meta
experience you could now book a trip to
see the walls of les cow on the walls of
Facebook approximately 10,000 years ago
men and women began to array themselves
with makeup they started to self
decorate but this wasn't for a seductive
purposes this was for religious
convictions we wanted to be more
beautiful pure cleaner in the eyes of
something or someone that we believed
had more power than we
there is no culture in recorded human
history that has not practiced some form
of organized worship which we now call
religion 6,000 years ago in an effort to
unite people our ancestors began to
design telegraphic symbols to represent
beliefs and to identify affiliations
these symbols connected like-minded
people and they are all extraordinary
these affiliations allowed us to feel
safer and more secure in groups and the
sharing created consensus around what
the symbols represented with these marks
you knew where you fit in both for the
people that were in the in-crowd and
those as importantly that were excluded
these symbols were created in what I
consider to be a very bottom-up manner
they were made by people for people and
then shared for free among people to
honor the higher power that they ascribe
to what's ironic is that the higher
power actually had nothing to do with
this
these early affiliations they often
shared identical characteristics which
is rather baffling given how scattered
we were all over the planet
we constructed similar rituals practices
and behaviors no matter where we were
anywhere on the globe we constructed
rituals to create symbolic logos we
built environments for worship we
developed strict rules on how to engage
with each other with food with hair with
births with death with marriage and
procreation some of the symbols have
eerie commonalities the hand of God
shows up over and over and over again it
shows up as the hamsa hand in
Mesopotamia it shows up as the hand
Fatima in Islam it shows up as the hand
of Miriam in Judaism now when we didn't
agree on what our beliefs and behaviors
were in regards to others if we felt
that somebody else's were incorrect we
began to fight and many of our first
wars were religious our flags were used
on the battlefield to signify which side
of the battlefield we belong to because
that was the only way to be able to tell
friend from foe we all looked alike
and now our flags are on
mass-manufactured uniforms that we are
making logos on products to identify a
maker came next and brands were given
legal recognition on January 1st 1876
with the advent of the trademarks
Registration Act the first trademarked
brand was bass al and I kind of wonder
what that says about our humanity that
the first trademarked brand was an
alcoholic beverage now here is what I
consider to be the first case of branded
product placement there are bottles of
bass al behind me with the logo
accurately presented here in this very
famous painting in 1882 by Edouard Manet
one of the most widely recognized logos
in the world today is the Nike swoosh
which was introduced in 1971 Carolyn
Davidson a graphic design student
originally created the logo for $35 upon
seeing it Nike CEO Phil Knight stated I
don't love it but maybe it will grow on
me maybe it will grow on me but why is
this whoosh so popular why is this were
so popular is it the mark or is it the
marketing and what can we make of the
fact that the Nike swoosh
seems to be the Newport logo upside down
or the Capital One logo on its side
that is not the only logo with a shared
identity
this next logo is a logo that has a
shared identity with wholly different
meanings as a Jewish person I believe
that this logo this swastika is the most
heinous logo of all time but it actually
has a rather surprising trajectory the
word swastika originally comes from the
ancient Sanskrit word swastika which
actually means good fortune luck and
will being in the early 1900s before it
was appropriated by Hitler it was used
by coca-cola on a good luck bottle
opener the American biscuit company
prominently registered the mark and put
it on boxes of cookies the US playing
card company registered the mark in 1921
for fortune playing cards the Boy Scouts
used the mark on shoes in 1910 and the
symbol was also featured on cigar labels
Box Tops road signs and even poker chips
even the Jane made use of the logo along
with a hand of God many millennia ago
these marks were identical but with use
as a Nazi symbol the impact became very
very different the hand of God the Nike
swoosh and the swastika they all
demonstrate how we've been manufacturing
meaning with visual language over
millennia
it's a behavior that's almost as old as
we are today in the United States there
are over 116,000 malls and they all look
pretty
the same there are more than 40,000
supermarkets and they each have over
40,000 items if you went shopping for
bottled water
you'd have over 80 options to choose
from
since their launch in 1912 you can
choose from over 100 flavors and
variants of Oreo cookies now is this a
good thing or is it a bad thing is a
plethora of choice necessary in a free
market I believe it is both a good and
bad thing as humans are both good and
bad
and we're the ones creating and using
and buying these brands however I think
that the question of whether this
behavior is good or bad is actually
secondary to understanding why why we
behave in this way in the first place
here's the thing every one of our mass
marketed products of what I consider to
be top down brands they're still created
by people but they are owned operated
manufactured advertised designs promoted
and distributed by the corporation and
pushed down and sold to the consumer for
financial gain these corporations have a
responsibility to a PNL with an
expectation of an ROI and have names
like P&G and AT&T and J&J and that's
pretty much the way it's been for the
last couple of hundred years a top-down
model controlled by the corporation
until 2011 that's when we began to see
evidence of real significant
far-reaching change the Arab Spring and
Occupy Wall Street proved how the
internet could amplify messages and
connect like-minded people with powerful
beliefs to inspire change
we witnessed a cultural shift via social
media with hashtags like niju and black
lives matter in its wake the discipline
of branding has transformed more in the
last 10 years than it has in the last
10,000 and for the first time in modern
history the most popular influential
brands are not brands being pushed down
by the corporation
they are brands being pushed up by the
people for the people for the sole
purpose of changing the world and making
it a better place
our greatest innovations aren't brands
providing a different form or a
different flavor of our favorite snack
our greatest innovations are the
creation of brands that can make a
difference in our lives and reflect the
kind of world that we want to live in in
November of 2016
Krista sue Jana's Wyman and Kat Coyle
created a hat to be worn at the Women's
March in Washington DC this was the day
after the presidential inauguration two
months later on January 21st 2017
millions of people all over the world
war handmade pink [ __ ] hats in support
of the women's March all over the world
the Hat was not created for any
financial benefit like our religious
symbols created thousands of years ago
the Hat was created by the people for
the people to serve what I believe is
the highest benefit of branding to unite
people in the communication of shared
ideals the pink [ __ ] hat became a mark
for a movement in a very short time two
months it became universally
recognizable it connected an audience in
an unprecedented way it is a brand but
it is more than that today the pink
[ __ ] had is proof positive
branding is not just a tool of
capitalism branding is the profound
benefice tation of the human spirit the
condition of branding has always its
always reflected the condition of our
culture it is our responsibility to
continue to leverage the democratic
power branding provides and it is our
responsibility to design a culture that
reflects and honors the kind of world we
want to live in thank you
[Applause]
[Music]